♪ ♪
>> Greg: BIG NEWS FOR PEOPLE
USING OR BEING USED BY TWITTER.
THE TIME SUCKING TOOL MAY BE
DUMPING THE LIKE BUTTON.
THE CEO BELIEVES THAT SINCE
PEOPLE ARE MORE LAX ON THEIR
COMMENTS, IT MIGHT BOOST THE
ATTENTION GRABBING QUALITIES OF
THEIR TWEETS.
THAT'S BAD.
TO ME, THAT'S LIKE REMOVING
SEAT BELTS ON THE HINDENBURG.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE ACCESSORIES.
IT'S ABOUT THE THING ITSELF.
DOES IT TWITTER HAVE ANY PURPOSE
AT ALL OF THE ATTENTION SEEKING?
NO ONE EVER TWEETS GET OUT, YOUR
HOUSE IS ON FIRE.
TWITTER IS THE WORLD'S BATHROOM
WALL.
NO ONE IS BETTER ON TWITTER THAN
THEY ARE IN REAL LIFE.
THEY ARE AVATARS WITHOUT SOULS
BECAUSE WITHOUT FACE-TO-FACE
DIALOGUE, CUES ARE MISSED AND
COWARDICE RULES.
IS THE PERSON BEING SARCASTIC OR
MEAN?
WHEN READING TWEETS, DO YOU
CARE?
IT'S MORE FUN TO CONDEMN THAN
COMPREHEND.
THE SAME BIASES EXIST THERE IS
ANYWHERE ELSE.
THE CEI PROTECTS LEWIS VERY CAN
WHILE BANNING OTHER VOICES AND
THE FIRST MISTAKE WE EVER MADE
WITH TWITTER IS THINKING IT
MATTERED.
THE WORST PART IS US.
OUR WILLINGNESS TO BE USED,
WITHOUT CONTENT, THE PLATFORM
WOULDN'T EXIST.
JACK DORSEY WOULDN'T BE WORTH
5 BILLION BUCKS.
HE'S A GUY GETTING RICH OFF DOG
BITES AND WE ARE THE MUTTS.
I FEEL LIKE I AM USED EVERY DAY
THAT I AM ON TWITTER.
>> Jesse: I KNOW WHEN YOU ARE
HAVING FUN ON TWITTER.
IT'S 8:00 OR 9:00 AND YOU
STARTING GETTING LOOSE AND YOU
SAY THINGS YOU SHOULDN'T SAY.
I LIKE GREG'S TWITTER FEED
BETWEEN 8:00 AND 10:00.
I DON'T PARTICIPATE IN TWITTER.
I WALK A FINE LINE AS IT IS ON
TELEVISION.
I LIKE TO TWEET AND RETWEET
THINGS I SAY ON THE AIR.
I NEED THE LIKE BUTTON.
I NEED TO FEEL LIKED.
THE MORE LIKES I GET THE BETTER
I FEEL ABOUT MYSELF.
>> Greg: AT LEAST YOU ADMIT
IT.
JUAN, YOU STAY AWAY.
>> Jesse: 11, DON'T GO ON
TWITTER.
AS YOUR FRIEND, PLEASE DON'T GO.
>> Juan: HAS COMMERCIAL VALUE
BECAUSE IT CAN PUBLICIZE
PROJECTS AND APPEARANCES.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK IT
SELLS ANYTHING.
>> Dana: I THINK IT CAN ALERT
PEOPLE TO SEGMENTS COMING UP BUT
SALES, NO.
>> Juan: IT'S A LOFT OF EGO.
I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU SAID IN
THE MONOLOGUE BECAUSE TO MY
MIND, THERE'S SUCH A LACK OF
RESPONSIBILITY THE PART OF THESE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH THE
FACT THAT MORE THAN HALF OF
AMERICANS SAY THEY BEEN HARASSED
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
DEMEANED, PUT DOWN, TROLLED.
I THINK IF THEY WERE
RESPONSIBLE, INSTEAD OF SAYING
WE WANT TO FACILITATE GOOD
CONVERSATION, BUT THEN THEY
DON'T PROTECT AGAINST PEOPLE WHO
ARE VICIOUS AND VILE AND SORTED
IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY SAY.
IT'S DAMAGING TO OUR COUNTRY AND
SOCIETY.
>> Greg: COULD YOU ARGUE,
MORGAN, THAT IT PROVIDES RELIEF?
SO PEOPLE AREN'T VILE ON THE
STREETS, LIKE THE TROLLS END UP
LETTING IT OUT ONLINE.
THEREFORE IT REDUCES INCIDENTS
OF VIOLENCE.
COULD IT BE A POSSIBILITY?
>> Morgan: MAY BE BUT I THINK
EIGHT OR TEN YEARS AGO WHEN
TWITTER WAS YOUNGER, THERE WAS
AMAZING THINGS HAPPENING ON
TWITTER.
IN THE 2009 IRANIAN GREEN
REVOLUTION THAT ALMOST OVERTHREW
THE ADMINISTRATION, THAT STARTED
ON TWITTER.
I WAS LIVING IN THE MIDDLE EAST
IN 2011 DURING THE ARAB SPRING.
A LOT OF THOSE REGIMES FELL.
THE ARAB SPRING HAPPENED BECAUSE
OF TWITTER.
IT HAS DEVOLVED SINCE THEN BUT I
WAS IN THE MIDDLE EAST IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WE WERE AMAZED
HOW SOCIAL MEDIA WAS BRINGING
DOWN 30-YEAR AUTOCRAT REGIMES.
PERHAPS THERE'S A WAY TO GET IT
BACK.
>> Greg: IT'S A FAIR POINT.
>> Jesse: TRUMP.
>> Greg: HOW MANY TWITTER
FOLLOWERS DO YOU HAVE?
>> Dana: A LOT.
>> Greg: IS BECAUSE YOU ARE
EXPLOITING YOUR DOG.
JASPER HAS NO IDEA HE'S ON
TWITTER.
>> Dana: HE IS NOT AS USED AS
YOU ARE.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH TWITTER
AND THE LIKE BUTTON, WHEN THEY
CHANGED IT FROM A STAR TO A
HEART, HE CHANGED EVERYTHING.
YOU DON'T WANT TO LOVE
SOMETHING.
YOU STARTED, THAT'S GOOD.
HEARTING IS GROSS.
THEY SHOULDN'T OF DONE THAT.
HAVE YOU EVER HAD COMPLETES FROM
PEOPLE IF YOU LIKE THEIR TWEETS.
COULD YOU RETWEET IT?
I WONDER IF WE SHOULD ABSTAIN
FOR A WEEK FROM TWITTER.
>> Greg: WE SAY IT BUT WE
NEVER DO IT.
>> Dana: I DID IT WHEN I WENT
TO SPAIN.